c'est le 13 août 1996 que marc dutroux
avait été arrêté cette affaire devait
provoquer souvenez vous un véritable
séisme en belgique au fur et à mesure
que l'on allait découvrir les
monstruosités des crimes qu'ils avaient
commis notamment en compagnie de sa
femme match et c'est ici qu'il faut
creuser l'an cynique un marc dutroux
arrêté quelques jours plus tôt le
pédophile est venu en personne avec les
gendarmes indiqué l'endroit où fouiller
la belgique découvre alors les visages
de julie et mélissa deux fillettes
disparues depuis de longs mois le début
du cauchemar accusant tour à tour ses
complices du trou joue avec les
enquêteurs
un mois plus tard en septembre 96 il
avoue deux autres moeurs année fieux
sont retrouvés enterrés sous son hangar
pour les parents la souffrance puis très
vite la colère car le pédophile était
bien connu de la justice il avait déjà
été condamné en 89 pour séquestration et
viol tout un peuple se pose alors la
même question pourquoi les enquêteurs
n'ont ils pas suspecter plutôt cet homme
tout un pays et mais une même hypothèse
du trou et protégés non ce n'est pas
leur fait que de crier à 6 le blasphème
résidait plutôt dans l'hypocrisie yeux
ou d'or de pieuses déclaration qui
voudraient étouffer les pourquoi que
notre coeur est votée nous tous se
reposer pour ne pas étouffer la vérité
c'est la marche blanche 350 mille
personnes viennent à bruxelles
soutenir des parents devenus les porte
parole d'une belgique en souffrance pour
lever les soupçons
une commission denquête se met au
travail audition après audition les
parlementaires découvre l'incompétence
des gendarmes
le dysfonctionnement de la justice la
guerre des polices
mais dans un rapport rendu public en
février dernier il conclu non du trou
n'était pas protégée il ya quinze jours
le pédophile avait été pour la première
fois confronté aux parents at il commis
d'autres enlèvement at il tout avoué
depuis dutroux ne dit plus rien
l'instruction n'est toujours pas close
son procès est attendu en 99
il